Let's take a moment to make
something insanely clear.
As far as battery's
concerned, networking
is the biggest, baddest,
dirtiest offender there is.
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and the largest wins
that you can get with
respect to battery efficiency
are going to come from adjusting
how you use your networking
hardware.
Remember that inside your phone
is a small piece of hardware
that's effectively a ham radio.
Its whole purpose is to
communicate with local cell
towers and transmit data
to them at high volumes.
The trick here, though, is
that the chip isn't always
active in drawing power.
It starts in a
powered down state
and then when some
data needs to be sent,
it turns on and
transfers the data.
Once the packet is
sent, the radio chip
will stay awake for a
while just in case there's
a response from the server.
If there's no activity after
a certain amount of time,
the radio will then go
back to sleep in order
to save battery life.
What's important
here is understanding
that at each stage of
the radio's life cycle,
it draws different
amounts of battery.
See there's a high battery drain
when the chip first wakes up,
some additional spikes when
packets are sent and received,
and then finally, a continuous
draw for the duration of the
keep awake time.
As such, optimizing
your networking hardware
that uses battery
has everything to do
with when you transfer data
and how you transfer data.
Let's start by taking a
look at the when part.
Firstly, understand that there's
a difference between networking
tasks that have to happen
right now versus ones
that can be delayed.
For example, the
user clicks refresh
to load a new batch of tweets
for a trending hashtag.
Since this is a
user-initiated action,
your app should
respond immediately,
which is a different
kind of work
than uploading analytics data,
or sinking background tasks,
or resizing all of
your social photos.
Well the first set has
to happen immediately
in order to provide
feedback to the user.
The second set can
easily be deferred
or pushed it off
until a later time
when it may be more efficient
for the battery to do so.
You can see how bad
of a problem this
is by running Battery Historian
and looking at the mobile Radio
Row for your application.
Each of those red
bars represent when
the mobile radio is active.
Any gaps between
those bars represent
when the radio is asleep.
If you see lots of
narrow bars and gaps,
this can point to
performance problems
since it means that you're
churning through lots of wake
up and sleep iterations
for your radio chip.
Now you can improve
this pattern slightly
by deferring work at run time.
That is, rather than
doing a request each time
it's being demanded, instead
batch all that work together
and execute it in one large
push at a future time.
You can see the
result of this back
in Battery Historian,
which you'll
see large blocks of red activity
coupled with large gaps.
The battery
improvement here comes
from removing the
per instance wake up
and wait costs and averages is
it over a number of requests.
And, of course, you
can defer that work
to an even later time, like
when the phone is on Wi-Fi
or plugged it.
In both cases,
networking requests
will be a lot more
efficient on battery.
Of course, the problem is that
writing code to batch, cash,
and defer all these
networking requests
can be a really, really
difficult job to get done,
which is why we've
done it for you.
The job scheduler
API that rolled out
with the L release of
Android provides a full suite
of functions that do all of this
work and more on your behalf.
Make sure you take a look.
Now for the stuff that has to
happen right now-- like pulling
down those awesome
hashtags-- you
can still do a lot of things to
help reduce the burden there.
Firstly, you should take
advantage of pre-fetching.
Effectively, try to
predict what the user might
need in the next five to
10 minutes, or one to five
megs of data,
whichever is larger.
And fetch that
content ahead of time.
So that you can
eliminate the burden
of those smaller individual
requests over that future time
frame.
Secondly, make sure that your
highly compressing any content
that you have control over
uploading or downloading.
In general, the battery
performance of the CPU cycles
needed to compress or
decompress that content is often
going to be much lower
than the overhead of what
the radio would use to transfer
that payload across the net.
And if you're ever wondering
how your app is using
its networking resources, check
out the Networking Profiling
Tool inside of Android
Studio, which will give you
a broad overview of
run networking requests
recur, how long they
occur, and how much data
they transfer along
the way with them.
But of course, there's tons of
other things that you can do
to help optimize battery
draining in your applications,
which is why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns resources
and join the Google+ community
for other great advice from
developers in the trenches.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.